it is a real honor to be here tonight I
I have to say you know none of these
films look like student films they are
the real thing
welcome guys you know in goodness lugar
s del mundo a linguist is only do my
extra hero
to translate in some parts of the world
English is a foreign language no matter
what language we speak or where we live
films allows us to see into other
cultures and other experiences and films
shorten those differences and they make
him smaller this year the foreign
category receive entries from 32
countries that is really really great
and I'm very very happy to see you young
filmmakers here from around the world to
be recognized tonight the winning films
are Border Patrol
but Peter Bauman from the modern film
school in the United Kingdom in this
black comedy German border police can't
catch a break as they try to get to get
out of work to go home and watch a
soccer game no see one by a Leonard roof
from the University of television and
film Munich in Germany it's a thriller
about a paranoid schizophrenic on a
quest to save his girlfriend but is she
real and Paris of the water by Alice I
alone from Tel Aviv University in Israel
this heartfelt drama shows how a couple
of married aging actors deal with
devastating life-changing news